tenemos el siguiente problema dice
cuando
1.125 gramos de un hidrocarburo líquido
y aquí nos dan que el hidrocarburo es cx
h pero no conocemos xy así que este
hidrocarburo es desconocido dice cuando
hizo combustión en un aparato como el
que se muestra en la figura y aquí está
más o menos el el aparato en por el cual
se realiza esta reacción que se está
planteando dice
3.447 gramos de dióxido de carbono y
1.647 gramos de agua fueron producidos
así que déjenme volver a subrayar todo
este enunciado para plantearlo en un
problema de este que o metría
subrayar todo esto
todo esto entonces qué es lo que nos
dice dice teníamos un hidrocarburo que
reaccionó con oxígeno entonces tenemos
el cx h y que reaccionó con oxy con con
oxígeno este por supuesto está en su
forma líquida y el oxígeno como siempre
está en una forma gaseosa y esto
reaccionan y nos producen dos cosas
primero que nada nos produce dióxido de
carbono en su estado gaseoso y también
nos produce agua muy bien h2o ahora bien
lo que tenemos aquí es que no podemos
balancear esta ecuación esta ecuación no
la podemos balancear porque no tenemos
cuántos carbonos y cuantos hidrógenos
teníamos
sin embargo lo que sí tenemos es cuántos
gramos de cada uno de estos reaccionaron
para bueno si se necesitaron y cuántos
se tuvimos como resultado para esta
reacción entonces tenemos este
hidrocarburo que requirió
1.125 gramos ahí tenemos gramos por
supuesto aquí estamos pensando que el
oxígeno es excedente es decir teníamos
todo el oxígeno necesario para poder
llevar a cabo esta reacción y teníamos
solo
1.125 gramos quiere decir que este
hidrocarburo es el reactivo limitante
este es el reactivo
limitante muy bien
ahora bien teníamos por otro lado
3.447 loops 3
3.400 47 gramos de dióxido de carbono y
teníamos
1.6 47 gramos de agua ok todo esto es la
masa que tuvimos de los productos
terminemos de leer el problema dice en
un experimento aparte la masa molar del
compuesto resultó ser de
86.2 gramos por mol entonces de esta
sustancia resulta que teníamos 86 punto
gramos y déjenme ponerlo de esta forma
gramos de nuestro hidrocarburos x h y
por mol de cx h de todo esto para tener
este digamos que sea que concuerde con
la anotación que ha estado llevando en
otros vídeos anteriores dice determinar
las fórmulas empírica y las fórmulas
empíricas y moleculares para el
hidrocarburo desconocido cx h y y lo que
tenemos que recordar es que la fórmula
empírica es la proporción más simple de
átomos que puede tener esta molécula es
decir esta molécula puede tener no sé
digamos 3 y 10
3 carbonos y 10 hidrógenos y su
proporción entonces sería 10 entre 3
digamos y es la proporción de los
hidrógenos sobre los carbonos muy bien
lo que vamos a buscar en la fórmula
empírica es la proporción muy bien y
para obtener la fórmula molecular la
fórmula molecular esto es exactamente el
número de carbono e hidrógeno por cada
molécula de este hidrocarburo muy bien
entonces la empírica es la proporción
que hay entre el número de átomos de
hidrógeno y el número de carbonos en
cada en cada molécula mientras que la
fórmula molecular es el número exacto de
átomos de carbono y átomos de hidrógeno
que cada molécula de este hidrocarburo
tiene entonces la idea de cómo resolver
este problema es la siguiente vamos a
tener que encontrar primero la fórmula
empírica y después tendremos que
utilizar la masa molar para esta para
esta sustancia para poder encontrar la
fórmula molecular muy bien entonces
vamos a ver cómo haríamos esto
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla y
entonces lo que hay que observar o más
bien recordar es que en la proporción o
más bien el número de carbonos y de
hidrógenos que hay del lado de los
productos debe ser el mismo que del lado
de los reactivos ahora bien del lado
derecho podríamos realmente encontrar
cuántos moles de carbono y cuántos moles
de hidrógeno tenemos verdad tenemos la
masa que tenemos en el lado de los
productos y podríamos calcular la masa
molar de cada una de estas sustancias
fácilmente así que la proporción que
haya del lado de los productos debe ser
exactamente igual que la del lado de los
reactivos
sin embargo notemos que del lado de los
reactivos uno de ellos es el oxígeno y
no tiene ni carbonos de hidrógenos
quiere decir que esta proporción que
encontremos del lado derecho es
exactamente la proporción que tendremos
en nuestra sustancia o en nuestro
hidrocarburo muy bien después de eso ya
vamos vamos a hacer lo siguiente ya que
tenemos la proporción utilizamos la
información de la masa molar para poder
encontrar exactamente cuántos de ellos
tenemos yo sé que a lo mejor puede sonar
un poco complicado pero si lo hacemos
paso a paso verás que no tiene mayor
este no no es tan difícil muy bien
entonces empecemos viendo cuánto o cuál
es la masa molar del dióxido de carbono
co2 muy bien entonces recordemos que la
masa atómica del carbono es 12 y tenemos
aquí 2 oxígenos y cada uno tiene una
masa de 16 así que la masa molar de este
dióxido de carbono es de 44 muy bien
quiere decir que esto
vamos a ponerlo así el dióxido de
carbono tiene 44 gramos vamos a poner
los gramos de dióxido de carbono por
cada molde de dióxido de carbono muy
bien ahora bien nosotros tenemos
3.447 de estos bueno gramos verdad
entonces tenemos
3.400 47 gramos de dióxido de carbono y
yo quiero saber cuántos moles tengo en
realidad así que necesito multiplicar
por algo que digamos tenga abajo gramos
de dióxido de carbono y por supuesto que
arriba tenga moles de dióxido de carbono
esto para que estas unidades se cancelen
con estas y solo nos queden moles
entonces si te fijas esto que tenemos
aquí tiene gramos de dióxido de carbono
entre moles de dióxido de carbono si
nosotros hacemos
la multiplicación por el inverso
multiplicativo tendremos 1 entre 44 por
moles de dióxido de carbono entre gramos
verdad simplemente invertimos todo y de
esta forma nosotros podemos cancelar los
gramos y nos queda nos queda
3.447 entre 44 moles de dióxido de
muy bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es hacer estas cuentas tenemos
3.447 entre
44 y nos da
0.07
834 ok seronero bueno vamos a quedarnos
hasta el 4 vamos a anotar esto entonces
estos son
0.07
834 moles de dióxido de carbono muy bien
esto es el número de moles que tenemos
de dióxido de carbono del lado de los
productos vamos a ver qué ocurre en el
lado de para el agua para el agua el
peso atómico o perdón el peso molecular
o la masa molecular del agua es de vamos
a ver cada hidrógeno pesa 1 así que
tenemos dos hidrógenos
cada oxigeno tiene una masa de 16 y
tendríamos entonces 18 gramos de agua
por cada
de agua entonces la masa molar es d
18 es de 18 verdad 18 sin embargo
nosotros tenemos
1.6 47 gramos de agua por quien
tendríamos que multiplicar para obtener
el número de moles pues no tenemos que
otra vez hay que multiplicar por algo
que abajo tenga gramos de agua y arriba
tenga moles de agua muy bien y eso
nuevamente vuelve a ser el inverso
multiplicativo de esta de esta cantidad
que es 1 entre 18 verdad entonces los
gramos de agua se cancelan y sólo nos
quedan moles de agua y nos quedan 1.6 47
entre 18 entonces tenemos
1.6
47 sobre
18 y esto es 0.09 15 ok entonces esto es
esto fue
0.09 15 déjenme hacerlo un poquito más a
la izquierda para que me quepa
0.09 15 moles de agua muy bien y ahí ya
tenemos cuántos moles de dióxido de
carbono teníamos en los productos como
producto perdón y cuántos moles de agua
teníamos como producto muy bien ahí lo
tienen ahora qué es lo que sigue sabemos
que cada que todos los carbonos y los
hidrógenos vienen justo de nuestro
hidrocarburo ok entonces sabiendo la
proporción en los productos sabremos
también la proporción de carbono e
hidrógeno de este hidrocarburo así que
cuantos cuantos moles de carbono
teníamos en esta en esta sustancia en lo
que es el dióxido de carbono bueno del
dióxido de carbono sólo teníamos un
carbono así que tendríamos exactamente
0.07 834 moles de carbono muy bien sin
embargo aquí tenemos dos hidrógenos por
cada molde de agua quiere decir que esto
de aquí hay que multiplicarlo por dos
verdad entonces tenemos
0.09 15 por 2 tenemos cero punto 183
tenemos cero punto 183 moles de agua y
eso es porque de agua de perdón de
hidrógeno eso es porque tenemos dos
hidrógenos por cada molde de agua muy
bien entonces si queremos ver la
proporción que hay entre hidrógeno y
carbono simplemente hay que hacer esa
división tenemos cero puntos pero si el
perdón
0.18 tres moles de hidrógeno divididos
entre
0.0 7
moles
moles de carbono muy bien y esto vamos a
ver cuánto nos da tenemos punto 183
dividido entre
0.0
7 834 si lo puse bien y esto nos da 2.3
3 597 vamos a redondear loa
2.336 entonces esto es aproximadamente
2.3
36 moles de hidrógeno
por cada gol por cada molde de carbono
ok esta es la proporción que hay ahora
bien si nosotros multiplicamos arriba y
abajo por cualquier número la proporción
sigue siendo la misma y fijémonos que
esta parte de arriba esto es más o menos
como
22 enteros un tercio verdad más o menos
así que si nosotros multiplicamos por 3
vamos a cancelar los tercios y nos van a
quedar aproximadamente un número entero
por ejemplo 22 un tercio si lo
multiplicamos por 3 sería 6 más 1 que
son siete moles de hidrógeno y para que
no se cambie la proporción abajo también
multiplicamos por lo mismo que sería
tres moles de carbono muy bien y lo que
ganamos con esto es que ya tenemos una
proporción entre números enteros entre
números naturales y eso está bien porque
pues las sustancias del número de átomos
que tiene una sustancia no pueden ser
fraccionarios verdad son exactamente
números enteros
de hecho podemos verificar esto por
ejemplo dos puntos
perdón 2.336 x 3 es
7.008 que para mí eso prácticamente es
un 7 no está bien entonces y esta es la
proporción que hay así que la fórmula
empírica ya podemos obtener la la
fórmula empírica es la siguiente la
fórmula
empírica
lírica es la siguiente la que tiene
siete moles de hidrógeno y perdón 77
átomos de hidrógeno y tres de carbono es
decir tendremos el c3
h7 muy bien ahora bien como obtenemos la
fórmula molecular recordemos lo
siguiente que al inicio teníamos
86.2 gramos de esta sustancia
sobre moles de esta sustancia que es el
hidrocarburo entonces vamos a pegarlo
acá para recordarlo
ahí lo tienen y cómo podríamos utilizar
esto bueno podríamos utilizar un poco de
álgebra para encontrarlo pero esta forma
es la si esta es esta forma es es
sencilla cual es la masa molar de estas
sustancias digamos que así fuera la
fórmula exacta de nuestro hidrocarburo
cuál sería su masa molar tendríamos tres
veces la masa del carbono que es 12 + 7
veces la masa del hidrógeno que es o no
estos son 36 + 7 son 43 verdad entonces
tendríamos 43 gramos del hidrocarburo /
por cada molde este hidrocarburo
entonces tendríamos 43 gramos de nuestro
hidrocarburo c3 h 7 por cada
de este hidrocarburo
sin embargo notemos que la masa molar de
la sustancia original es de 86.2 que
esencialmente es el doble de esta
sustancia muy bien quiere decir que
teníamos 22 de ésta digamos tendríamos
en realidad 6 carbonos y 14 hidrógenos
es decir teníamos el doble de esto para
tener el doble de esta masa molar y que
coincide con lo que el experimento nos
indicó así que nuestra fórmula molecular
la fórmula
la fórmula molecular que es ya la
cantidad exacta de átomos de cada
sustancia sería de 3 a 7 y tendríamos
dos de estos que en esencia sería un c6
h 14 y ahí lo tienen esta tiene la misma
proporción digamos de
átomos de hidrógeno respecto de carbono
que está de acá arriba verdad ambos
tienen como proporción 7 entre 3 aquí
sería 14 entre 6 que también es 7 entre
3 sin embargo la masa molar de esta
sustancia ya coincide con el resultado
experimental no sé tú a mí me pareció
este ejercicio muy entretenido nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo